doors are closing okay great i'm just
gonna go
so i'm gonna start by saying that buyer
sensors are awesome so you take just a
random human being
like this one with a bit more hair you
slap on a few sensors and you've got
data so i think this is like a dream for
data scientists right you can do all
this data science and machine learning
on your own personal biological data and
i'm going to show you how to do that in
this 30 minute talk
so
if you're a citizen data scientist like
myself you like playing with biosensors
in your spare time there are a bunch of
them available on the market for
consumers
and these are basically the types you
can easily
afford there are eeg sensors for
measuring your brain waves so you can
actually measure your your brain waves
non-invasively and control things with
that there are emg sensors for measuring
the electrical signals from your muscles
i'll be mostly talking about that
and also things you can easily do is
like measure heart rates and also lots
of other biosensors but these are the
ones i've played with
mostly
so
there's of course plenty of applications
you can imagine for biosensors the first
one which is my specialty is bionics so
bionic arms for example they use these
muscle sensors to control
the arms
but there are also plenty of other cases
like in medical you can imagine all
kinds of diagnostic applications in
gaming and especially in vr
big companies are really thinking about
putting your head chuck full of buyer
sensors and measuring everything about
you while you are gaming and there are
also plenty of consumer normal consumer
applications like
sensors to help you relax during
meditation but also sensors to help you
focus during programming for example so
plenty of things you can do with these
biosensors
and my own use case was mostly related
to bionics so a few years ago we thought
let's
start helping people
making more affordable bionic arms and
one of the things we invented was the
idea to make a learning environment
where people could train their muscles
in a more fun way
and have an ai also help them control
video games and then basically you can
collect data while they're playing games
and you can also control by building a
glimpse
and there are maybe some other
advantages we came up with
now there were a bunch of technical
obstacles and this year i personally
redid the whole project with new
technology so i'll be talking about that
and one of them is julia
another technology
is solving another problem which is this
one
there are plenty of buyer sensors on the
market and if you buy a few and you want
to quickly try them all out it quickly
gets complicated because all these buyer
senders they have
a different interface they work
differently
and then you they work on different
operating systems you want to apply in
the end your code on different
applications in different environments
and and this really slowed our project
down a lot we had to every biosensor we
bought we had to figure out again how it
worked
but this has been solved also in the
past years i'm really happy to say and
this is an open source library
that's called brain flow
am i also now a contributor because i
really love this library and it is
trying to integrate all these buyer
sensors in in in one package it runs on
any operating system and also what i
really love is that it has bindings to
any programming language so you can do
it in python but i'll of course be doing
it in julia and then you can really
focus just on you know playing with your
data instead of wrestling with your
device
so i really encourage anyone who wants
to go in this area to to look at brain
flow
now and then you can say okay now i've
got brain flow i got my data which
language do i actually want to use
you're free now
now
in my project we use a lot of python and
c plus plus c plus plus for like
performance and python if you just want
to quickly
get your data but from my point of view
i think c plus and java they are too
much effort for me to write and uh yeah
i just want to quickly prototype things
and then python and r often actually
they were too slow as a programming
language if i built my own custom data
signal processing so i went for julia
this year yeah i rebuilt the whole
project from scratch
in julia because it is indeed fast and i
wanted to prove it was fast enough for
my use case
and there's plenty of data science you
can do with it and i'll i'll briefly
show you as well
so we're going to just get going
the first thing you do before you do
machine learning is looking at all the
data
now that first you need to get the data
and in brain flow actually it's very
simple they have the same interface in
roughly every programming language you
just use the package you install it
you start let's see
you
you choose your board so i use here the
geforce pro board it's one of the
sensors you'll see later
you can input parameters but it's often
not necessary then you start up this
object here
okay and then the cool stuff happens you
turn you make sure your sensor is turned
on okay and then you prepare the session
it makes the connection for you so in
any programming language you can do it
it's all the same then you start your
stream
then you just get your data then you do
stuff i'll show you the stuff later and
if you're done you stop the stream and
you you disconnect the device by
releasing the session and that's it and
you can do this for any device in any
programming language okay i really i
really like this
and then
okay if you get the data you want to
plot now in python you probably all have
your favorite plotting package
in julia if you're new to julia you have
to first
find your way around again so i looked
at all the plotting packages in julia
and
the them actually they seem to be
converging mostly on the plots package
so if you want to get started in julia
with plotting i would say take a look at
the plots package
because it's really integrating all the
back ends so you can switch
back ends very easily between pi plot
and plotly and gnuplot and whatever you
prefer
and with again the same interface there
are also a few others still that i
looked at there is
vega light for example it's like a
grammar of graphics
language and they just made a wrapper
for it so if you like the gg plot in r
then this is maybe your first starting
point and there's one other language
that's still competing a bit with the
plots ecosystem it is maki
and maki is really a high performance
plotting library and actually i use this
to visualize my raw data
and yeah so that's what you can can look
at if you want to play with julia
yourself
now let's look at the signal so if you
slap on the sensor on your arm
the signals basically look like this you
when you
when you relax there's some background
noise
and then when you flex your muscle like
you make a fist uh
you can you get this alternating pattern
that gets higher in amplitude and when
you relax again it gets lower so this is
basically the thing we need to detect
and classify and
analyze
and then the thing is i have a sensor
with eight
eight channels
so here's my wife i will show a quick
video and we can we can see all the
eight different channels
for different kinds of gestures
i wrote everything down in a blog so you
can go and look over there if you wanna
know the details
it's actually a blog on the brainflow
website
but let's look at the video let's see if
it works now you can see
what the raw data looks like
yeah so you see my wife is making some
gestures and here you see the raw data
streaming in the marquee
plotting package this pretty high
density data you see every if you look
carefully you see that every gesture
kind of gives a different unique pattern
across the different centers because
every every gesture basically activates
different
muscles right so here's the raw data in
a static plot by the way looking at the
data is really fun you can look at it
for hours looking at your own personal
data
so but but we want to do some data
science right so basically we need to
classify this i've got these gestures
and i want to detect them from the raw
data now you as a human maybe if you
look carefully you can already see some
differences
like these are the eight channels right
like for example if you do a flex in one
direction it will activate mostly
sensors on one of the muscles and if you
flex on the other direction you see the
other
sensors activating so you know i bet we
can do some machine learning on this
right
now a quick into metso in julia because
you are all python people right so
you're using pandas a lot and if you
switch to julia you're gonna use the
data frames package i really actually i
enjoy the data frames package more than
pandas i think it's more convenient more
more user-friendly so you can just make
a data frame you just assign it to a to
a column you can assign afterwards to a
column
i like that you can just index things
like a matrix officially i used a lot of
matlab in the past and it's more like
more like matlab actually but there's no
eye lock and that kind of weird things
that i always need to look up and you
can also just choose the columns by name
i found you can very easily do group by
and because julia's really fast it just
gives you a pointer to the data so you
can actually mutate the data of the
original object just right there i i
mean i just love julia okay and then you
this is how a data frame looks like on
the repo
so just a quick
if you're scared there's no pandas
there's this thing
then
let's go to the machine learning okay so
you got your data and your pandas and
all your matrices now we want to do some
machine learning
all right there are a bunch of again you
know you're new to julia so there are a
bunch of machine learning
frameworks in julia
there is flux there's also
tensorflow.jail but flux is like the
pure julia implementation of the neural
networks so you can just read the source
code
there is of course scikit-learn which
just calls the python package that's
very easy by the way in julia to call
python packages there's also mlj which
is machine learning in julia
so that's like the overarching
integrating framework it seems to become
in in julia and basically what it does
it it makes it easy to set up pipelines
and do all these kind of experiments
that you want to do and it just calls
all the underlying packages so it can
call flux it can actually call cycle
learn and these can also call a lot of
the independent packages so i like in
julia that they didn't integrate
everything in one big thing they you can
you can if you look one look at every
like decision tree xca boost nearest
neighbor you can look at all of them
individually and these packages
basically just give you an integrated
interface so you have the freedom to
choose which you prefer
i actually prefer just to get the
individual packages and i'll show you
how i did that
so yeah again i really like julia if you
you know and if you want to read the
source code you know just go do it right
i mean i've never read the stenzer
tensorflow source code but i read the
flux source code so if you want to see
how is a
loss function implemented in julia you
just go here to flux you look for the
mean square error and it's there
actually you know it's it's it's
embarrassingly simple you just take the
difference you square it and you take
the aggregation which is by default the
mean
and that's it i mean if you want to
implement your own loss function just go
ahead right do it it's very easy i like
that
uh
so we're going to build now a machine
learning
model right
so this is basically the flow that i
built myself
it always starts by connecting your
device right you want to get the data
with brain flow
then what i did i made a little script i
put it in a package
that got us all the recordings per
gesture so basically for two minutes i
just tell myself to do one gesture all
the time so you get the raw data per
gesture and then you you can label it
then most of the work actually is always
as you know in all the data engineering
and the signal processing not the
machine learning so i spent a lot of
time uh partitioning all the samples in
nice little packages making them easy
for the algorithm to train on
processing the data properly there's
lots of stuff happening over here but in
the end you've got basically the thing
you want to fit and you've got a big
matrix of samples basically i sliced
all these little samples out of
out of all these
all these signals
and then of course yeah you know machine
learning is easy you just do a fit right
so and then you save it
yeah
so base what i did i'm not going to show
you all the code that i used here
oh yeah wait oh yeah but okay we want to
we want to pick an algorithm okay so we
in the past already in python we
looked at all the old algorithms see how
they performed on the data and if you
process your data bit bit intelligently
you can find plenty of algorithms that
work pretty well
so what in the end what i said for my
prototype that i'm going to show here
today is i just pick a random forest
because the random fours seem to be
pretty good and they're also nice and
fast so i just yeah i just use that one
so the code
i'm not going to show you all the code
but it roughly look like this so i put
all my data engineering in a nice little
package which you can install because
you know you make your code reusable i
you also do that right you don't just
throw scripts over email
yes yes so i
i just slice it i window it yeah
and in the end when i do the live
prediction basically the algorithm sees
one sample all the time so i slice it
exactly the same way as what i want to
predict in the end and i put all the
channels behind each other
yeah that was the simplest way because
they are there
yes yes you will see some flickering in
the final demonstration so it definitely
things can be improved yeah
definitely but for the prototype it was
all uh fine okay so i i i could get
pretty good i mean there are
there's a massive ecosystem of academic
papers on how to get to 99
i i just take the sample i don't put in
the algorithm i get i can get often yeah
eighty to ninety percent uh accuracy so
it's good enough for me okay as my as a
hobby data scientist
so that's what i do i
i made a nice little package to to
process all the data if you want you can
go and read about it
i i load all these files
and then when i do the training yeah you
can use the whole mlj the sky psychic
learn stuff but i just use the decision
tree there's also actually i found out
also you can do a cross-validation in
there even
and and check it look at your accuracy
and then in the end i just put all the
data in the build forest i get the model
i save it with this jld2
julia data serialization it's like
pickle but again in pure julia
and then i've got my model right and
then i want to do the thing that is most
interesting most cool to demonstrate i
got to do live predictions right
uh
so again i connect my my
my
my biosensor with blamefro
i load my model right it's very simple i
load it
uh you know i start my stream
i i use maki here i very simple for this
demonstration i just make a text
a block of text and i will update it
continuously and then i've got a loop
where i get the data i make the
prediction and i update basically the
plot it basically the code looks like
this you know i get some data with
rainflow i use my package to process it
exactly like during the training
i apply the forest and then i basically
here i can update this marking node very
quickly with with the gesture
and basically you get this video
so here's my hairy arm with the very
center
yeah my arm and there you see the this
note from maki and the code and there we
go let's see how it works
so i'm making these gestures
you see live
i'm predicting the gestures right and
sometimes it flickers a bit see so it's
not absolutely perfect but i think it
works pretty well actually
yeah
so
so we did it right
we got the data we can make predictions
now the only next step is to actuate
something and
for this prototype the very simplest
thing you can do is press a key
and if you can press a key you can play
a video game so actually the next video
is immediately
clear i i got my wife hooked up and i
got her to play a video game
let's see
how that looks like so there's a nice
little video game here's the sensor
and she's trying to
so a move when she squeezes it's like a
gym
and when she moves back and forth it is
just
you know doing that
let's see
oh
that's
it so that's actually the whole
presentation how long it did yeah
so we got there
if you want to start playing with
biosensors
well first you need to buy one that's
that's the biggest obstacle but then you
can just start using brain flow we
always need more users
we definitely need open source
contributors
sponsors and partners is still something
we're looking for and what i'm thinking
would be really cool in the eindhoven
area maybe there are other people with
biosensors like me we could maybe start
organizing workshops and hackathons and
just lower the threshold
to get started with biosensors and if
you want to know more just go ahead and
visit brainflow
that's it thanks for being here
okay
time for questions
i'm gonna do this
one thing about julia that's kind of
nice oh yeah
you can dockerize anything of course
but
you get four megabytes
yeah
this is actually an interesting question
we because i'm also pushing a juliet
asml
and we want to deploy it on embedded
systems
there's the package compiler which can
compile julia into a standalone library
but libraries are still a bit big indeed
they're like
you can get down to 100 150 megabytes
yeah it's better than python
and definitely better than model up yeah
so it's
actually
we're going to pay uh julia computing
we're paying them in julia 1.8 we'll
make them smaller so we'll get down to
like 30 40 megabytes
yeah and maybe we'll get even better you
know it's still evolving and yeah
we can really make this a the best
language on the planet
next question
so
so this question is a little bit in the
other direction uh have you considered
calling julia from python i i heard
about these packages that yeah just for
the parts where you need to speed so
that you can still work on python yeah
you can just do that yeah is there any
limitation like any downside to doing
that
uh i think the data marshalling is going
via c so it's even you can i think even
past data in memory to python actually
with c it's it's beautiful the c
interface is like a native c interface
so between c and julia is a lot of love
and between actually julian python also
a lot of love
uh so i don't i haven't seen any
downsides i mean yeah you need two
installations that's the only downside
right you need more dependencies yeah so
i like to keep things pure julia
we still have time for questions
okay
go for it
yeah are pretty good
no that's me that's just me repeating
the gesture yeah so this is like i have
here a five second sample from my two
minute uh
data collections yeah that's what you're
looking at over here
yeah that's a good one actually uh so
there's plenty of things i can improve
here because indeed when i when you
quickly switch between motions the the
algorithm i train isn't so good at it
because it basically expects always a
like a pause you know in between the
so always a relaxed motion between in
between them so that's definitely an
improvement actually there's many many
improvements we can do like if you turn
take off the device and put it back on
you know there's also some variation in
the sensor data so yeah
from a robustness point of view there
can be many many improvements in the
algorithm yeah and in the data
processing
maybe
over the seat
i was wondering how well it works if
you train the model on the data for one
person or for
more persons so if you switch the
sensors to a different arm how well will
it work
yeah it uh
it'll be worse
so indeed it's best to collect a lot of
samples from a lot of
already from yourself from different
positions yeah so you become more robust
against that indeed from the other arm
and
if you indeed across people
i know it works because uh there are
there the manufacturers of the company
there was a myo sensor in the past i
don't know if you know it was a startup
they made it they mass produced it and
they had an algorithm that could work
pretty well from human to human but if
you calibrate it on yourself personally
it just gets better you know
and also actually facebook is nowadays
working on a device it has like uh
20 sensors or something and they really
want to use it to control their their vr
worlds with it so it is possible yeah
but i'm not a i didn't go that far let's
say
yeah i saw in the video you were using
your own arm and uh your wife's arm yeah
but you can also rotate the sensors and
it will still uh you get different
training data yeah yeah yeah it's
possible yeah you can train for that uh
but you need more data yeah so the
easiest if you just want to be quick in
a demonstrate like in a workshop you
just do two-minute samples and you keep
it in place yeah then you get like 90
accuracy it's the best demo
okay thank you
thanks
questions
oh there's one here
uh
uh first great stuff thanks for
the introduction of this uh i actually
saw the let's see the videos actually
presented like i'm have i'm just like
curious
we check if the precision of the arm
band gonna actually have an impact on
the final result because it seems like
uh
yeah it's like always some somewhere
it's like upper um
yes yes yes yes because like if you're
near the wrist probably you have like
more movements from the ligaments and
muscles yeah the patterns of the data so
we need the the the position of the
sensor on the arm you mean that's what
you're asking definitely that makes a
lot of difference so these are men's
they're like roughly the size on the the
optimal position is indeed roughly here
that's where you have the strongest
signals yeah indeed but there are
wristbands that also measure here but
you just have lower signals
ah so those things are always like fixed
in this position that's the best
position uh okay so studied uh to death
by lots of phds yeah this is the best
position for the sensors but you can
measure actually anywhere as a muscle
you can measure these signals it's just
a matter of signal quality
versus sensor
quality there are also like
you know people that don't have an arm
and they for example i know one
experiment where they chopped up the
breast muscle and put different emg
sensors on the different
things and the the that person learned
to control a whole arm
with the by controlling different
muscles in his chest yeah not a cord
okay so that's also possible yeah
there are many many many possibilities
all right thanks